so far we've learned that critter
junction has decided to go with cloud
run for their layout app
will they learn to optimize cloud run
for scalability
stay tuned
to refresh the layout app is a key part
of the game
you can share house layouts with other
players and since containerizing their
nodejs
application they've decided to run it on
cloud run for its portability
statelessness and auto scaling even to
xero
and unlike their online site running on
app engine they haven't needed to write
warm-up wrappers in their code because
cloud run may keep some idle instances
around to handle spikes in traffic
the thing is cloud run will terminate
unused cloud run containers
after some time which means a cold start
can still occur
after looking at recent deployments of
the layout app we noticed a few things
that could be improved to minimize cold
start latency
first they happened to be using a
dynamic language with dependent
libraries
like importing modules in node.js they
weren't using global variables
and their container-based images were
about 700 megabytes in size
this meant that overall they were facing
longer load times upon container startup
or required additional computation
before the server could start listening
for requests
instead they want to optimize their
service startup speed to minimize the
latency that causes these
let's dive into each for starters
on cloud run the size of your container
image does not
affect cold start or request processing
time
but you want to be careful when it comes
to applications written in dynamic
languages
for example if you're using nodejs or
python
module loading that happens on process
startup will add latency
during a cold start also be aware of
some modules that run initialization
code upon importing
to build a leaner service you can
minimize the number and size of
dependencies if you're using a dynamic
language
instead of computing things upon startup
compute them lazily
shorten your initializations and speed
up time to start your http server
and use code loading optimizations like
php's composer auto loader optimization
next up global variables in cloud run
you can't assume that service state is
preserved between requests
but cloud run does reuse individual
container instances to serve ongoing
traffic
that means you can declare a global
variable so when new containers are spun
up
it can reuse its value you can also
cache objects in memory
moving this from the storage request
logic to global scope means better
performance
a lot of this boils down to creating a
leaner service
you want to build a minimal container by
working off of a lean base image like
alpine
distroless or scratch these images
reduced critter junction's image size
from 700 megabytes to 65 megabytes
they also made sure to only install what
was strictly needed inside the image
in other words don't install extra
packages that you don't need
once critter junction was able to remove
dependencies
use global variables swap to a leaner
base image
and remove extra packages they were able
to reduce the latency of any cloud-run
cold starts
now there are other best practices for
cloud run scalability and performance
so be sure to check out the link below
stay tuned and remember
always be architecting
[Music]
you